as moviegoers around the world no Jackie
Chan has always been full of surprises
he surprised me the very first time I
met him 30 years ago I had flown to Hong
Kong to shoot a commercial with a
superstar called single I hadn't heard
of but as soon as he walked in it was
like that's Jackie Chan that's not
sing-along
but that was his Chinese of course I
recognized him instantly I knew him by
his distinctive loping walk his giant
smile and by the cloud of infectious
exuberance that surrounds him wherever
he goes
Jackie is a generous performer he is as
generous to his co-stars as he is to his
audiences but I will say that he's also
highly competitive the problem is so am
I where we were making Super Cup we went
toe-to-toe if I did a stunt then Jackie
would have to do even more amazing one
and I would have to be bad and so on
until finally Jackie pulled me aside and
said we have to stop you roll off the
roof of a car I have to roll off the
roof of a building you jump on the moon
the Train on a motorcycle I could do it
in the helicopter if this keeps up I'm
gonna end up winding dead
but you survived like always many show
business veterans have received
governors awards over the years but
tonight Jackie Chan is the first little
boy to win one his friends and his fans
know that Jackie has discovered the
secret of eternal youth he is exactly
the same as the day I met him honest
funny kind and despite the years still
possesses an astonishing physical
prowess